so choose your mate wisely and that's
perhaps the good segue into sexual
selection humans I could tell you you're
good at this
uh who said why did I bring up sexual
selection it's good relationship so um
it's extra selection in humans even I I
don't think you've done an episode on
relationships
no I did um an episode on attachment
right
um but not on relationships the the
series with Conti includes one episode
of the four that's all about relational
understanding and how to select a mate
based on matching of drives and all the
the the the the Demons Inside the
subconscious how to match demons and
they dance well together or what and how
generative two people are what does that
mean means that um how the way he
explains it is how devoted to creating
growth within the context of the family
the relationship with work well let me
ask you about mating rituals and uh how
to find such a relationship
I mean you're really big on friendships
on the value of friendships I am
um
and that I think extends itself into a
one of the deepest kinds of friendships
you can have which is a romantic
relationship
what uh What uh uh mistakes
successes and wisdom can you impart
well I've certainly made some mistakes
I've also made some good choices in this
realm
um
first of all we have to Define what sort
of relationship we're talking about if
if one is looking for a life partner you
know potentially somebody to establish
family with with or without kids with or
without pets right families can take
different forms
um I mean I certainly experience being a
family in a prior relationship where it
was the two of us and our two dogs and
it was like it was family like we had
our little family
um
I think
based on my experience and based on
input from friends who themselves have
very successful relationships I must say
I've got friends who
um are in long-term monogamous
very happy
uh relationships where there seems to be
um a lot of love a lot of laughter a lot
Challenge and a lot of growth
and both people
it seems really want to be there and
enjoy being there
just to pause on that one thing
to do I think by way of advice is listen
to people who are in long-term
successful relationships that's like uh
it seems dumb but like like uh we both
know and are friends with Joe Rogan
who's been in a long term really great
relationship and he's been an
inspiration to me so you take advice
from that guy definitely and several
members of my podcast team are in
excellent relationships I I think
um one of the things that Rings true
over and over again in the advice and in
my experience is you know find someone
who's really a great friend like build a
really great friendship with that person
now obviously not just a friend if we're
talking romantic relationship but
um and of course sex is super important
but it should be a part of
that particular relationship alongside
or meshed with the Friendship uh
can it be a majority of the the positive
exchange I suppose it could but I think
the Friendship piece is extremely
important because what's required in a
successful relationship clearly is
joy in being together
Trust
a desire to share experience both you
know mundane and and more uh adventurous
um support each other
um acceptance
um a real uh
maybe even admiration but certainly
Delight in being with the person you
know earlier we were talking about peace
and I think that that sense of Peace
comes from knowing that the person
you're in friendship with or that you're
in romantic relationship or ideally both
because let's assume a healthy relation
the best romantic relationship includes
a friendship component with that person
it's like you just really Delight in
their presence even if it's a quiet
presence
um
and you Delight in seeing them Delight
in things right
um that's clear uh the trust piece is
huge
um you know and and that's where people
start I you know we don't want to focus
on what works not what doesn't work but
that's where I think people
start engaging these covert contracts
they're afraid of being betrayed so they
betray
um they're afraid of giving up too much
vulnerability so they hide their
vulnerability or in the worst cases they
feign vulnerability
um again that's a covert contract that
just simply undermines everything it
becomes one equals two minus one to
Infinity
conversely I think if people can have
really hard conversations this is
something I've had to work really hard
on in recent years that I'm still
working hard on but the Friendship piece
seems to be the thing that rises to the
top when I talk to friends who are in
these great relationships it's like they
they have so much respect and love and
joy and being with their friend is the
person that they want to spend as much
of their non-working non
uh platonic friendship time with and the
person that they want to experience
things with and share things with and
um and it sounds so kind of canned and
cliche nowadays but I think if you step
back and examine how most people go
about finding a relationship so I'm like
oh like am I attracted of course
physical attraction is important in
other forms of Attraction too and they
sort of enter through that portal which
makes sense that's that's the mating
dance right that's the peacock situation
that's hopefully not the Cuttlefish
situation
um but but I think that
um there seems to be
a history of people close to me getting
into great relationships where they were
friends for a while first or maybe
didn't sleep together right away yeah
that they actually intentionally
deferred on that
um this has not been
my habit or my experience you know I've
gotten the more
um I think typical like oh there's an
attraction like this person there's an
interest you kind of explore all
dimensions of relationship really
quickly except perhaps the moving in
part and having kids part
um which ideally because it's a bigger
step harder to undo without
um more severe consequences
but I think
the whole take it slow thing
um I don't think is about getting to
know someone slowly I think it's about
that physical piece because that does
change the nature of the relationship
and I think it's because it gets right
into the more hardwired primitive
circuitry around our feelings of of
safety vulnerability
um you know there's something about
uh romantic and sexual interactions
where it's almost like
it's like assets and liabilities right
where people are trying to figure out
how much to engage their time and their
energy and multiple people I'm talking
about from both sides you know male
female or whatever it sides but where
it's like assets and liabilities and and
that's where it starts getting I um into
those
complicated contracts early on I think
and so maybe that's why if a really
great friendship and admiration is is
established first
even if people are romantically and
sexually attracted to one another then
that piece can be added in a little bit
later in a way that
really kind of just seals up the whole
thing and then who knows maybe they
spend 90 of their time having sex I
don't know
um that that's not for me to say or or
decide obviously but there's something
there about
staying out of a certain amount of
um
uh risk of having to engage covert
contract in order to protect oneself but
I I do think like
uh
love at first sight this kind of idea is
uh in part realizing very quickly that
you are great friends like I've had that
interesting experience a friendship
recently just it's not really friendship
but like oh you get each other with
humans not not in a romantic setting
right friendship yeah just friendship
but not but dare I say I felt that way
about you when we met right but we also
this dude's cool and he's smart and he's
funny and he's driven and he's giving
and he um and he's got an edge and
um like
I want to want to learn from want to
hang out with them like that I mean that
was the beginning of our friendship was
essentially you know that set of of
internal realization I'm going just keep
going that good keep going shark dresser
yeah yeah it just looks great shirtless
on Horseback yes no no no listen I mean
it's despite what some people might say
on the Internet it's a purely platonic
um friendship somebody said uh somebody
asked if Andrew cooperman has a
girlfriend and somebody says I think so
and the the third comment was this
really like uh breaks my heart like that
uh Alex and Andrew are not a not an item
we are not we are great friends but we
are not an item that's true it's
official the um uh
I hear over and over again from
friends that have made great choices and
awesome partners and have these
fantastic relationships for long periods
of time that can seem to continue to
thrive at least that's what they tell me
and that's what I've observe
establish the Friendship first
and give it a bit of time before
sex and so
you know it
I think that's the feeling that's the
feeling and and these are we're talking
micro features and macro features we're
talking you know and this isn't about
perfection it's actually about the
imperfections which is kind of cool I
like quirky people I like characters
I'll tell you where I've gone badly
wrong where I see other people going
badly wrong
if there is no rule that says that you
have to be attracted to all Attractive
people
by any means it's very important to
develop a sense of taste in romantic
attractions I believe what you really
like in terms of a certain style you
know a certain way of being and of
course that includes
um sexuality
um and sex itself the verb but it I
think it also includes there's just
general way of being you know and when
you really adore somebody you like the
way they answer the phone and when they
don't answer the phone that way you know
something's off and you want to know and
so I think that
um
the more
you can tune up your powers of
observation not looking for things that
you like
and the more that stuff just kind of
washes over you the more likely you are
to quote unquote fall in love as a
mutual friend of ours uh said to me you
know listen when it comes to romantic
relationships if it's not a hundred
percent in you
it ain't happening and I've never seen
a violation of that statement
where it's like it yeah it's mostly good
and they're this is like the
negotiations already you're you're it's
doomed and that doesn't mean someone has
to be perfect the relationship has to be
perfect but it's got to feel 100 inside
like yes yes and yes